if you guys want to take away from liver
King and this is what's wrong with
Society especially social media is when
when people are at a certain level
everyone wants to tear them down this is
not news is everybody's surprised
everybody knew and in fact it was always
tongue-in-cheek with this guy this guy
Brian Johnson has been playing a
character this was a this was a
marketing thing he's been playing a
character uh it seems to have worked I
think it is some it's a heightened
character but it's also it's a character
right is he it's an exaggerated version
of himself yeah but he's actually a
really good human being that's why I
care about the guy yeah of course he's
on [ __ ] his message overall look
prioritize 10 000 steps a day well
that's healthy that's healthy healthier
walk Barefoot connect to the Earth he's
saying work out get sun sleep and eat
eat another page but when you look at
his body no one was no one was under the
illusion if if you're now like what I
got news for you Liberace was gay if
he's selling supplements and a lifestyle
um people are mad because he's saying
you can have this body he's never said
that no no I know I I've looked in this
he's never said if you do exactly what I
do on this Primal program you're going
to look just like me get to my body fat
get to this muscle no no his whole thing
is living a healthy lifestyle yeah but
you could make the argument you could
make the argument that he's talking
about a healthy lifestyle and if he's
doing all these drugs that's not so
healthy
fire
[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
yeah we're good chin I like that card
again
cardigan holiday cardigan keeping his
mid body warm gotta keep the mid body
warm it is a little chilly out um
um it is a little chilly out
I like it very much where's that where's
Daddy we both got some name seven a.m
flights tomorrow yeah I just got a 7-85
flight 5 AM go time going to Naples
Florida our boy Eric and Virginia I
can't wait to hang with us restaurant
the best guy and uh so that's off the
hook comedy club now Bubba I'm gonna be
there Thursday Friday Saturday now it's
sting a little bit There's Sunday too
they're Sunday too yeah taking the
Lord's day well I'm pushing against the
Sabbath because because Florida makes me
feel a little Unholy and here's the
thing well Naples doesn't yep and and
it's looking like it's looking out
Saturday Sunday is on its way to be sold
out which is very surprising on a Sunday
in Naples but people come out to last
Sunday well it's a Sunday Bubba but
listen I like Naples I stay at a very
cool hotel I got the beach I'm bringing
baby and and wifey interesting movie yep
interesting move baby and wifey that's
what happens to be 55 Bubba yeah you'd
rather spend time with your little
nugget yeah okay
daddy's gonna work that guys got some
stuff to do and then
um I'm gonna eat I'm gonna eat now every
time I come back from a show Eric
uh has got is the spread he's got the
spread and he's like bro let me just
start with some wines I'm like but Eric
it's a million o'clock yes tiger thick
there too I bet yeah I bet he's like
look like a little wine I'm like but
that's that's a Hundred Acre wine that's
that's a 600 I mean literally he's a fan
of the show he literally gave me a last
time he gave me a wheel of cheese he
adds a bit of a wheel of cheese it was a
wheel of cheese all I did was eat cheese
and the best prosciutto and then all the
the antipasto and they know how I repaid
them
I remember the last day we closed that
place down at three in the in the
morning and we're laughing and [ __ ]
around and making videos the whole thing
he's a great dude oh what a great time
great dude Naples God's elevator
uh yeah there's now here's the thing
about Naples and I always tell the story
and this is no [ __ ] in the middle of
the pandemic when I was even a little
apprehensive when I was like nobody
really knew and it was it was what it
was uh I'm doing
um stand up and when I tell you that not
only were people not
masked or six feet apart they were 80 70
and 80 sharing shrimp cocktail sharing
shrimp cocktail and laughing and
screaming and I was like no these people
are hardcore they were coughing each
other they were hard because I was there
too during the Panic they don't care no
they welcome it I was like all right
well you know demo that if you get it
you guys are they were like you know
what the hurricane I'll wash all this
covet away oh good talk by the way that
that hurricane hit Naples so hard that
on Fifth Avenue you know Fifth Street or
whatever it is Main Street really now I
don't know if you know this
people were taking boats oh yeah up the
[ __ ] Street didn't hit Virginia thank
God because I would have had a problem
now you know we're the best literally
the both best and most uh expensive car
collection Museum like kind of
automobile museum yeah in the United
States is that right no Naples really
because I said this to Sam tripley and
he goes well that's the swinger capital
of the world and it's where a lot of the
women have and this is his words Nazi
helmet tits and I don't know what that
means you're like hard with it I guess a
lot of there's older women with older
women with very fake breasts hard and
then the skin that's a that's a tougher
operation that's uh at the time I
thought that was a very interesting yeah
it was a very interesting description I
feel like there's some other
descriptions there I was like all right
shout out to Sam nobody better than Sam
at coming up with I mean you're not in
the cars but you would appreciate it I
mean Jay Leno keeps some cars there Adam
Carolla I mean you're talking oh really
they have one of ones they have a Paul
Newman car there like when I do
Neighbors yeah my dad didn't care about
my comic literally flying there is that
right same week on there he'll go to
that show on Saturday night he's just
going because that car Museum's there
wow Jay goes every time and you go there
and you just look at that those cars
yeah they're like Bugattis they have
like a McLaren uh F1 there original and
it's Jay Leno's it's sick your old time
if I say to you right now and I'm gonna
count I'm gonna now hold on
I'm gonna count to seven okay it's gonna
be seven seconds careful let's get a
loaded question is it
see this is the problem I know it's a
lot I'm gonna give you any card you want
dream car starting now one one thousand
two one thousand Bugatti uh
yeah Bugatti what we got the I think
it's the Chiron the new one the shyron
yeah bring that up chin the Bugatti
Chiron what's that what's that gonna run
me uh well there's so like the new one
there's they have one new one they only
made 16 of them that one I think they
only made 60. and here's the thing to
get the new one you have to be a
previous owner of two Bugattis okay
which are both well over two three four
five million dollars oh so you gotta be
uh oh boy yep now is that street legal
oh yeah Daddy that's street that street
now it's gonna go about you ready for
this yeah about 285 miles an hour
now there's no one like you because
you're one of those guys that will take
that car and actually drive it every day
oh that thing's going to the grocery
store that's what's so crazy about you
oh yeah no one does that no you did that
with your Ferrari Non-Stop and what
people don't realize is when you buy a
Ferrari the way you do
you're actually getting paid to to drive
that car it's a hustle yeah do you know
what I'm saying investment that's all
that's all the cars are investments yeah
I mean when you see a guy driving that
car chances are he's going to sell that
car for more than he made correct wow
look at that thing and there's a waiting
list and getting you can't just go into
a I can't just go into a Bugatti
dealership and say I want a Bugatti I
can't you gotta I can't no no no no no
you I mean you literally have to have so
it's the same as like same with fry or
Porsche unless you want to pay crazy
over asking price like that Bugatti
let's say you didn't you weren't in the
club oh my God look at that that one
Bugatti's 12 million dollars those are
8.6 million you're not even touching
those wow why so expensive dude they're
so rare like I said some of some of them
there's only like six of them there's
only eight of them in the world there's
30 of them this is the same company that
makes the motorcycles yeah and but then
also here now here's a catch Daddy yeah
so a you're gonna have to have think how
much money you have to have to afford a
2.9 Million Dollar Car well okay six
million after taxes right yeah and
that's gonna be money other than you
know mortgage just it's just lying
around yeah a lot of fun money but
that's an investment money so the way
people invest in houses you can invest
in that okay but again you're not gonna
be able to really touch it so well I
have a big question but then also here's
the here's the problem yeah chin bring
up
how much
is maintenance on a Bugatti every year
I think it's around sixty thousand
dollars a year no matter what no matter
if you put one miles or no matter what
no matter because the oil change they
have to take the entire engine out that
where you want to take it here oh no no
we're gonna we're gonna have to ship it
back to France right you have to ship it
back to Europe for them to do all that
what yeah they just ship it up pick it
what are you talking about so surgeon
made in a Bugatti costs nearly 500 000
every four years but God has always been
a choice for high servicing maintenance
costs which is uh considering the asking
price for the cheapest model is 2.5
million I mean but I'm sorry sir
500 grand every four years is obnoxious
that's [ __ ] off have a free make it free
well include it in the deal I mean
why they have to take the entire end so
uh this one says make better engines
so the car so here goes uh let's see a
car that has a starting price with seven
figures is always extremely high upkeep
of course a freshman hot tires yeah
you're right I'll get to that but how
much will maintain a Veyron and Tip-Top
shape actually cost you set your back uh
Manny says we gotta recommends all
fluids have to be changed each year and
that cost a hefty right this is the
every year twenty five thousand dollars
for the oil and other fluids so there's
a lot okay the guy the car has a
whopping 16 drain plugs or twice as many
compared to any other exotic vehicle or
regular cars the drain plug's not easy
uh accessible as the mechanics have to
take out the rear wheels and brakes as
well as the lining on the rear fenders
along with one underneath the back of
the car okay moving on to the wheels all
right okay so Bugatti advises that the
owners change the tires once every
couple years a fresh new set costs an
eye-watering thirty eight thousand
dollars for just the wheels you have to
be replaced every 10 000 miles okay for
staggering fifty thousand do the math
we're looking at around a hundred
thousand maintenance costs in just a
couple of years of owning this car ain't
for everybody it's not for everyone it's
where a hundred grand is 10 bucks that's
what you have to have now many have two
Veyrons and one-off shiron Hermes on the
way so the bills are even higher okay I
I don't know how to make sense of any of
this I mean the level you'd have to be
at just uh well a lot of people give
them they're not driving them right
they're just they're just like art
pieces like some people have them I've
seen you know these Scrooge mcducks who
have these the Elon Musk of the world
yeah the the you know these guys the
Iron Man's of the word the starts they
they literally have it in their living
room and just rotating okay now let me
let me ask you this that makes sense let
me ask you this no it doesn't look like
what are we doing well it's a shadow
it's a center piece I'll go ahead and go
and start that up get started out kids
are sleeping now now branding Shop's
driving it everywhere here's the thing
and you did this with your Ferrari and
what people don't realize is that I do
the GT2 yeah the problem is if it gets
hold on yeah now in a Bugatti I'd
imagine if you get
dinged you're gonna need the guy's
insurance
because well
I would imagine any kind of Bodywork
well here's no see you're not you gotta
use the old Noggin okay well you're not
going to want to report to Insurance
because what happened to report an
insurance that gets put on an official
file on uh the Carfax so then the value
goes
no matter what even if I take it back to
Ferrari well you would go and pay cash
or Trend finally away or go to private
Bugatti dealer is Cash let's not put
this on record because it's you know
ruined about now it's just like you ding
on the door it's not gonna get reported
if getting like a fender bender or you
got to replace a door that gets all put
down on the history and you're screwed
yeah I mean that's that thing you're
you're on the hook daddy so that's a
hundred grand or something oh yeah I
mean and forget getting actually when
they I've seen Ferraris that get pretty
beat up and they go it's totaled and I'm
like but you could fix it they're like
no no no no no no no no if the engine's
been [ __ ] up nobody wants to know
what's up so we'll see you we'll see you
later I mean just the the thing like
Floyd Mayweather has I don't know how
many people got it he does yeah
that's like when you see like Travis
Scott pulled up to that cats restaurant
in uh Hollywood one of my favorite
restaurants he pulled up there in the
new Bugatti it was like oh guys we've
got him that's not his it's nice no even
how much money he makes he's like you
know how big of a Gearhead you'd have to
be so so people somebody landed to him
oh 100 some dealer did gets the shine
where'd he get and you know some Beverly
Hills Bugatti or whatever some private
dealer went to come that night or
something like that that night that's
not for you now they have insurance when
they lend it Travis Scott that's part of
their in their business I'm sure
I I'd be nervous driving that I would be
nervous driving that thing unless I paid
for it then it's we're driving like we
stole and you're driving it's Grand
Theft Auto you are until I get a call
and he's like hey hey you know if you go
over a certain miles per hour you have
to replace tires in like next week it's
gonna cost you 50 Grand like we're gonna
stop driving is that true it's yeah
depends how you drive the car I'm sorry
it's exhausting but also hey Bugatti
yeah hey man yeah I want to drive this
hey Bugatti here's the thing make a car
for a million dollars 500 000 that I can
drive the [ __ ] out of dude I was
watching uh this you know my kids are so
into cars especially Bugatti so it was
like the top fast cars of 222.
I mean if you're not on if you're not
paying attention
it is mind-blowing why how fast cars are
these days really not talking about the
electrical Buzzy [ __ ] yeah not the
tassels and stuff that's what I really
don't count I'm talking about like these
these cars the V8 the V12 was 1400
horsepower 1600 horsepower 0-60 all of
them around 2-6 which is fine yeah some
three they don't care they care about
top end speed yeah oh my God so that
shirana super sport
305 miles per hour [ __ ] nuts those
Coatings you need a track 277 miles per
hour you need a track
or four or five let a nine hey
excuse me sir you see what I do in that
gt2rs down Topanga when I come home from
doing sets it is dangerous it's it's
ignorant uh
I'm deliberate
um I don't like cars anymore
well you know you're gonna get I'm sorry
to say this to you we're moving into an
economy that's going to outgrow oil and
that includes cars you won't be alive
mother oh no we will be oh no no oh
that's happening that's happening way
faster way faster in fact in about 11
years we're going to be there now listen
no I promise I've looked at all the
stats I've looked at the stats
I've looked at the stats and I don't
care what your buddy showed you now
listen no no it's not it's that Peter
diamandis it's team color it's too much
money it's the book oh yeah Texas and go
green oh yeah dude what's good you know
China's green how's that pollution going
no but what I'm saying is that all the
cars you're going to be on you're gonna
be you're gonna be driving on an
electric car I'm sorry no chance yeah
because they're not going to make them
illegal yeah they're just not gonna sell
them anymore you're not going to have
anywhere in 2032 they're gonna do it
yeah no matter casting you're gonna be
driving people going to be like ew
seriously I mean they do that now
seriously they do it now is that where
you're driving is that where you're
driving around my kids not a chance
you're gonna get that and you'd [ __ ]
deserve it you [ __ ] deserve it you
won't be alive by the time we're green
and you're dumb cars that you have are
going to be worth
all the money no money oh all the money
because people are gonna be like even
steam powered cars are worth so much
money so I mean I guess if you could
install it in my living room as an art
piece maybe but I don't have the room
that's what your car is going to be I
don't think so and it makes us more
reliant on China it's not going to
happen yeah well China's got China can't
they're wait they're way ahead of no oil
their way yeah well that's why they're
showing electric they own all the
electric charging stations the lithium
batteries it's nuts but they own all of
it they're ahead of us way ahead of us
so just leading more into China have fun
with that communist hey wait a minute
you can't say I have a comment yeah
you can't say that although I will say
that my [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] my Tesla is a
bigger carbon footprint oh way more so
than mine okay don't [ __ ] that's what
people don't understand way more
everyone judges
you know you're driving an eye no no no
dude my car is my car is sick handling
six speed yeah
it's so quietly dangerous I call it the
quiet assassin I call her the white
assassin not because I'm racist just
because it's got white interior and
white uh white cake what do you call it
the White Knight yeah I called the White
Knight
yeah because remember what I used to
call my my red Prius it was the the red
Ram the red Ram I stole that from a
comic a great comic uh who used to open
for me [ __ ] damn he called it the red
Ram he called his his uh charger the red
wrap oh you just took it down like that
I stole it oh wow yeah at least you came
out about it no I yeah you're not Carlos
I've always said that I've always I've
always said that I I I I drove it off
the lot and I made them call it the red
rant no I know you said that but I
didn't know you took that back from
somebody see how the see how my fingers
are like
Rams thing I stole that let's take a
little break from Chad and all things
liver King and everything else
interesting I have a question for you
when you wake up yeah the first thing
you do you check your credit score right
oh I think to myself if I live that
ancestral lifestyle am I gonna so so
then let me ask you this so so you don't
check your credit score but chime does
let me tell you why
Chimes credit Builder Visa credit card
you can start to build credit with your
own money how about that chime reports
your payments to credit bureaus to help
you build credit over time does it
affect a lot of people have a problem
with credits no wow you don't and a lot
of members see an increase of 30 points
on average yeah but does it is there
increased annual fee I'm glad you have
security deposits or credit checks no
annual fees no large security
departments and no credit checks to
apply bye oh my God I'm gonna start my
credit Journey with chime sign up takes
only two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score like Brian told you get
started at chime.com fighter that's
chime.com
Fighter the chime credit Builder Visa
credit card bank and they pursue another
license to the USA time checking account
200 qualifying directors
with a better credit card we're right on
time payment history can be positive
impact on your credit score impact of
score Omega Perry and students use the
scores command on improved out of
network ATM withdrawal fees May apply
except for MoneyPass ATM and 7-Eleven or
at all point and Visa plus Alliance ATM
they like the micro machine gun welcome
to rough and crowding special
announcement coming in hot added to
rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew with talbas
fight companion show who will be
watching it live with the boys we're
talking Theo Von Joey Diaz Rampage
Jackson myself
[Music]
oh goodness oh wow
what else you want tune in
speaking of doing bad things
um I had been it's all debatable whether
it's bad and I'm sure you've seen the
news on
former finally kid guest the liver King
and still welcome back at any time
and still welcome back at any time the
liver King now let's get into it so
um this person this is this bar stool
Sports yeah so uh Billy hot takes what
just found out liver King may have done
steroids utterly shocking could have
never predicted this I mean I mean
and so the guy who actually uh I like
this dude the place more dates uh Derek
guy he's great
um he released and Mark you know more on
this now Derek at Place more dates
posted uh an email from liver Kings is
it his doctor or is it some advisor like
isn't there HIPAA laws here like isn't
this illegal isn't somebody gonna be
sued here he uh was sent a heavily
redacted emails from a bodybuilding
coach who the liver King was
corresponding with it wasn't with this
one email it was like back and forth
like tell me everything about you
because if you are going to be a
bodybuilding coach you have to know all
these things routine what they're taking
now what they want to take what their
goals are what their problem areas are
give me pictures of yourself doing these
poses
um okay which actually pushed back and
he's like I have no time I don't know
what these poses are I need to do this
in the next 30 minutes yeah it was one
of the emails but he
forwarded this on we don't know who that
person is he forwarded it on to Derek
and Derek went through all these emails
that that would be more speculative if
it was just that you go maybe somebody
Photoshopped it but then Derek looked at
that email that sent the emails to this
bodybuilding coach and checked in his
own inbox and found that he had had
similar emails requesting consultations
on HGH and Annabelle from liver King
from uh you know this guy at ancestral
supplements whatever either Brian
Johnson or the liver kit whatever it is
but like we're presuming same email yeah
and also another email from somebody on
his team like asking something in that
vein too like but also it was before he
went public so it wasn't like in the
midst of his Fame it was before right
before because he also explained the
email he's like hey I'm going to launch
this you know uh Primal whatever it is
like Primal what's his Primal something
he's like before I launched this like
I'm putting up some of my money
investing my time in this I'm hiring a
team like yeah we're trying to reach 1
million followers like with my positive
message and he's like I gotta you know
look great great I can look the part
here's what I'm currently doing my
body's not responding to the HGH uh
igf-1 I'm taking 11 000 a month in uh
HGH which he's overpaying but so it's
like and then he breaks down the rest of
all the [ __ ] he's doing and I guess
but like like this was coming right like
we and then you and I got some blowback
because when liver King came on here
fans were like I can't believe you
didn't ask for if he's on steroids
[ __ ] what I'm listen let me just say
this this is not news is everybody's
surprised we all know everybody knew and
in fact it was always tongue-in-cheek
with this guy look this guy Brian
Johnson has been playing a character
this was a this was a marketing thing
he's been playing a character uh it
seems to have worked and it was always
done tongue-in-cheek at the end workout
he's saying work out get sun sleep and
eat eat another page good food but when
you look at his body no one was no one
was under the illusion if if you're now
like what then come on yeah it's really
good and I got news for you Liberace was
gay so yeah also exactly yeah like yeah
Adam Levine likes other women so the
thing is is with liver King like Adam
what Adam Levine yeah yeah yeah the the
singer yeah yeah he loves chicks yeah I
mean yeah he's rock star right Dime
Piece right but it's nothing like when
that came out everyone's like I can't
believe I'm like oh wow I don't realize
how stupid people were I mean so even
with him it's like when liver King came
on here if off the bat you're like come
on dude you're on steroids right now
he's notoriously I mean he's denied it
but he also talked about it like wasn't
it who said was it Logan Paul who said
why have you why don't you talk about
your steroid news somebody somebody said
Bradley Martin I think Bradley Martin
said what Bradley Martin because I was
talking Bradley yesterday because
Bradley's Bradley's in the community
he's like I don't get why people are
surprised he kind of like uh kind of
alluded to it on my paw you know kind of
was like
but here's my thing with all this like
hey if you're surprised you're just kind
of a dumbass like there's so many sheep
out there where if this if you really
thought he was on steroids and then B I
don't really care because his message
overall his message is health so if you
could please go back to his website Joe
that's why I want it up so his message
is health and you look at you know cold
plunges the cold tub he talks about
sleep eat move Shield connect cold Sun
fight Bond so the message is so positive
to me that outshines anything of course
he's on [ __ ] and I hate to tell you guys
whatever whether it's Joe Weider Arnold
Schwarzenegger whatever book that you
got as a kid or whoever you looked up to
they were on shipment it doesn't mean
they're bad people it doesn't mean
they're cheating the system and also and
also you got to realize that liver King
was and it is what it is was gifted with
a foundation where he's genetically
gifted so this stuff obviously enhances
that but he people have it confused
where if they take steroids they think
they're going to look like liver king or
all sorts you got to work your ass you
can take all the stuff you want if you
don't have an insane work ethic it does
not matter so to me when liver King came
in here assume he's taking [ __ ] but
don't care but I assumed the reason he's
successful is because of his discipline
and he does live that lifestyle whether
or not he's taking steroids it does not
take away from his message and that's
why we had him on the show I don't give
them yeah so for me he's actually a good
person I got a kick out of him going sub
Primal because I was wearing my
Invisalign yeah I always looked at him
as a very humorous American character
and a multi my buddy Brian Cooley said
it best he goes I listened to the liver
King and he sounds like a multi-level
marketer absolutely he sells supplements
he's got a whole business he came up
with a character to sell his business he
wears he wears pelts he wears no shoes
he's got a huge beard it's a [ __ ]
cartoon character he's doing he's got a
great sense of humor about it I think it
is some it's a heightened character but
it's also it's a character right is he
it's an exaggerated version of himself
yeah but he's actually a really good
human being that's why I care about the
guy yeah I don't give a oh of course
he's on [ __ ] but again his message
overall if you did buy into his program
look prioritize 10 000 steps a day well
that's healthy take a cold shower that's
healthy Barefoot connect to the Earth
yeah all that you got to remember and
again if you guys want to take away from
liver King and this is what's wrong with
Society especially social media is when
when people are at a certain level
everyone wants to tear them down they
want to take him down and they're like
he's a snake uh yeah well so people are
mad because maybe I would have to see
what he said
maybe what he's if if he's selling
supplements and a lifestyle
um people are mad because he's saying
you can have this body he's never said
that right he's never said that's my
question I don't know what he's doing we
have to be a little careful because
we're not sure we don't know I know I
I've looked at this he's never said if
you do exactly what I do on this program
this Primal program you're going to look
just like me get to my body fat get to
this muscle no no his whole thing is
living a healthy lifestyle yeah yes but
but but but you could make the argument
you could make the argument that he's
talking about a healthy lifestyle and if
he's doing all these drugs that's not so
healthy and I think some people are
going hold on you're you're you're
you're pitching Health but you yourself
are taking a slew of this probably cost
them a fortune and in fact all the
muscle and all this is a result of doing
something that's actually artificial
subprimal and not healthy so it is it
grates against the message so people
feel like they're being either lied to
or that he's lying the way I looked at
this is number one I never bought any of
his Pro I don't buy it I haven't bought
any of the stuff I just have always
found him entertaining as an American
character obviously he's a good marketer
obviously he's playing a character and
and I do agree that what he's saying the
message of Health the message that he's
saying is healthy hey B let me ask you
this to your point of yes uh snake oil
and all that stuff in line to people
yeah name someone the fitness space you
look up to name name somebody an
entertainment that you look up to who's
like a strong male give me one or I'll
go chin too not Mark Mark knows people
but
um like growing up who's a rock the rock
Chris Hemsworth Chris sure yeah Brian oh
you're talking about like the physical
people out there yeah guys guys guys men
men I admire Chase I admire Jake's uh uh
uh workout okay that's great no but I'm
talking like no I'm talking like uh
entertainment in the fitness like
entertainment I'm sorry like he's not a
competing athlete oh athlete athlete
different Stallone Schwarzenegger yeah I
mean um uh yeah I mean and there are
there you said the rock there are
certain athletes all the stairs he would
make he would make this look like a
short essay compared to the the amount
of [ __ ] running through the Rock's body
do you care that the rock is jacked and
preaching healthy lifestyle and working
out and his whole brand is Health go
back please go back to the liver King
The Rock's entire brand is Hell the
wrong was just talking about longevity
on it there you go he's like do you care
about like preparing for the roll more
or longevity like definitely
do you want to take the rock out next
like you got to pick and choose here you
got to pick and choose you want to take
the rock out
no no no I think um so so is it
dorothanized it doesn't matter you're
talking about a guy who is who is
selling supplements
um liver and bone marrow and nutrient
dense nose to tail diet all that stuff
okay
um and
there does seem to be uh there does seem
to be uh there's a lot of money being
made on selling supplements which is
healthy and when you sell supplements it
claims a certain outcome no I don't I
haven't looked there's no there's no
claim that if you take protein powder
it's going to look like him yeah
implication but yeah when I when I was
when I was 12 I thought if I took muscle
tech I'd look like Arnold look it goes
back to this it goes back to this B if
you're surprised that this man was doing
you deserve it you just I mean you're
you're it's that's hilarious yeah then
go get a booster I'm not I'm not you
know by the way I still think he's 100
natural and I'm sick of my guns
no but um you know at the end of the day
everybody in Hollywood that you look at
everyone at Hollywood
that you look at is doing so now look at
this this Chris Hemsworth preaching uh
he has this whole workout Fitness uh
Center power in an app he has an app to
get big and stuff like that yeah dude
should we take him out next now I don't
know if you have news or not
you have you seen when he's getting
ready to play Hulk Hogan you see how
massive he got the whole program Hulk
Hogan yeah
so those three jumping on there if we
take a piss test usada is Banning these
guys won't be allowed to fight for two
years in the UFC I mean I hate to break
everybody's heart out most of listeners
like yeah no [ __ ] so just so you know
like when I when I was gonna do a movie
with a big director he wanted me to gain
some weight muscle and I went to my
trainer he's sick he's a strong man he's
been in gyms his whole life he was 60 at
the time maybe 55 whatever and I said I
need to put on I'd walk up to him and
he'll like this and I go hey man I got
to put on 20 pounds of muscle here and
he goes like this he goes he goes he
goes yeah I go yeah he goes and how do
you want to do that I go well I don't
know I just maybe we should start
lifting heavier and then just give me a
diet plan and he looked at me and he
goes Brian you're a coat hanger
genetically I can't do that now
associate you never forget this he goes
if you give me two years and I put you
on gear I can maybe get you 20 pounds
heavier it'll be tough you eat a lot and
even that would be tough right because
I'm not so when you see a lot of these
guys
whether it's Zac Efron or whoever in in
these or if you look at the the cast of
most of the people in 300 what do you
mean most all of them did yeah everybody
is everybody would be so amazed in in
Hollywood
Dan Bilzerian said it Dan Bilzerian said
everybody everybody you you see in
Hollywood at one point or another is
doing something you know [ __ ] I might be
the only person yeah I might be the only
person you know really besides yeah it's
not your thing but you know what I'm
saying he's like of course is that is
that it's it's the height of naivete but
but here's still coming Daddy
so here's the thing you brought up 300.
remember 300 really started the surge of
um [ __ ] the [ __ ] you like uh crossed
it CrossFit the the Spartan workout
right yes now do you care that the
gentleman on the movie who are shredded
right and obviously there was some
graphics and shading and air spraying
going on but still those guys were
shredded they started a movement that is
actually really healthy yeah do you care
that the start of it was guys that were
genetically modified on PDS no the
overall message was this cool crossfit
workout I hate to I hate to express
CrossFit which I I'm a big fan of but
even in CrossFit if you look at fittest
on Earth if you look at the people who
are competing in CrossFit if you think
for a second that there aren't
some ped is being used in the CrossFit
world and all you have to do is go to
the CrossFit when it first started 10
years ago 15 years ago whatever it was
and Crossfit now take a look at some of
the women we've done this before but of
course everyone knows this yeah that's
what so surprising me like how outraged
some of the yeah a lot of people I think
don't like to be lied to and a lot of
people don't like to be uh they don't
like somebody who is claiming Ultimate
Health and very very I will say this
about the liver King we have to call
people as it is that's natural we have
to call well that's incredible is that
is that literally that's not the same
person is it I think it is I think it is
can you see anything uh Libertines
comments on steroids
but look at this one can you go down to
just go down right to that right the one
to the right yeah now Bubba
that's all natural though right
that's that's that's CrossFit of course
the best in the world of course not but
but here's the thing with steroids again
that the public don't understand take
all the steroids you can find okay
you're never going to be able to because
the amount of work that they put in to
get to that level it's nuts but I do
think Bubba that the liver King exposed
himself because he was very very
um
opinionated and insulting to other
people and I think when you do that was
he insulting yeah and it was very very
opinionated yes in a weird way I'm
grateful for the reason I have shed Line
This complete this [ __ ] topic
um um
do you understand what I'm saying so
when you're that when you're that
opinionated
about health be and you're that and you
have built a whole empire being that way
but he's not the first one to do it BSN
made billions of dollars selling
products with Ronnie Coleman next to the
[ __ ] bottle
I understand I'm just saying that I
think when you and that's alluding to
look like take this I take celtek you
look like Ronnie Coleman you built a
whole empire made a fortune by being a
sharp profile I call this a sharp
profile opinionated uh taking the fight
being you know loving like he's the guy
you love to hate he's the guy you love
has he said anything before on steroids
or not the recent ones yeah one of which
would be he did this prank on uh like he
goes here's the real secret and he has
like he opens this like you know capsule
of whatever bone marrow and it's like a
trend bottle and then he at the end he
goes this is obviously just a joke this
was my cameraman's idea I don't even
know where to get this stuff so it's
like he has denied it many many times he
he responds directly on podcasts but he
also like seemingly has gone out of his
way to like mock it and be like but then
I had like I don't even know where to
get this stuff so I guess you'd expect
that from you know anybody and and
bodybuilders of
I like his message on the the health
side of things if you do live that way
you're gonna definitely feel better and
probably live longer I'm all about that
I do think and he needs to take
accountability when the steroids did get
brought up to find a better way to do it
like the celebrities like if you ask the
rock dude they're politicians with it
you won't get an answer next you know
you're talking about [ __ ] you know
Fiji yeah like wait yeah there's a lot
of kids look up to him a lot of you know
people yeah so so so
he could have been and he needs to take
accountability and if he goes on a show
which I'm trying to help him out if he
goes on a long-form podcast is able to
express this he goes I think that's what
I think happened I think he should go I
[ __ ] up I gave you guys the impression
that I was all natural and you know I
have clearly and it's out there now I've
dabbled in PDS and steroids and HGH and
all that stuff but well you know I'm
saying like I've taken and I have ton of
stuff and I'm currently on it but that
doesn't take away from the fact my
overall message and the lifestyle and
the discipline I've I've lived for 35
years of continuous working out taking
care of my body putting the right food
the right uh I remember watch him but
then I would hold on be then I would say
then then I'd go you know I think it got
his Fame like blew up he went viral so
fast that it became this secretive
monster where he's like okay well I've
gone too far down the rabbit hole now I
say it's steroids I'm super [ __ ] and
but uh it's someone she got in his ear
went it's good they're gonna come for
you dude it's gonna come out buddy like
you should we should address this now
before we keep going down this road
because the long you wait the worse it's
gonna get so you just need to take
accountability yeah [ __ ] up
but the overall message is still there
yes you know yeah that that's a good
point dude I think it's like you know
the overall message ancestral living
there's something to be said for that
it's great I've Got Friends who've not
been doing it way before he came it's
not for me
and it worked for them I've seen it work
but um I do think that at the end of the
day the lesson here is I've I've said
this from day one man if you're lying in
one way or another and especially if you
build an Empire on a lie you're gonna
get it's gonna find you yeah you're
gonna get found out and you wish
somebody from his team were like hey I
know it's got out of control and it's
like you know you're doing all this
stuff but you should address this at
some point so this is part of my take
liver King uh admits to taking PDS on
part of my take and that was a but no so
he made a joke about it it was like
performing endurance and something like
he made the you know it become a
difference Bradley Martin claimed that
he admitted it on his show or alluded to
it I'd love to see the actual clip
because that's what Bradley Bradley told
me that livestock and Brad last night
Chicago dude how about Luther King I'm
saying I'd love to see yeah I mean I
would do I've never seen it yeah I don't
I challenge you a little bit
we talked about the truth why do you not
tell people about your steroids
this is a great question right because
of what implies okay right I think a
better question really is it's the same
question do you take things yeah but my
answer has been the same because I've
always told the truth and you can say or
think whatever you want of course right
but but at the end of the day like this
is what my message is really all about
yeah is it's the nine ancestral tenants
and did you know 50 years ago we had on
average 50 higher testosterone yeah so
if you just think about that right we
could probably go 50 to 100 higher just
by doing the nine ancestral tennis we're
back to normal isn't that what most
people do with they're trying to do
steroids to increase your testosterone
by 50 to 100 for the most part well and
so I don't know exactly what the numbers
are but what I'll say is this like if
somebody has let's say 700 you know
testosterone that's high and and if
they're taking steroids and they want to
get up to 1400 1500 or whatever guess
what you can do the same thing with the
nine ancestral tenants no you can't and
if you do the nine ancestrals you might
be able to this is where he gets in
trouble I don't know if he can say no no
what he just did there was he said hold
on he said oh he did on Bert Show too he
said he said he said
uh that's a great question at the end of
the day if you have 700 testosterone you
want to bring it to 1400 you can you can
do that with the the nine Etc that'd be
tough that's not true you can't so what
he's doing is he's he's not asking her
the question and he's saying take my
Doom do what I'm selling and you don't
need steroids so I can understand why
people are I'm sorry is that not a
positive message Obi yeah it's would you
rather wet it would be easier a little
snake oil it's a little snake oily Bubba
also he didn't admit it it's a little
snake he admitted it I'm gonna show him
like and and and I can see why people
would now go let me did you do it on
yeah it's gonna be tough to do well you
can't look I'm not defending that you
did that or if I did that you'd call me
and go hey what the [ __ ] are you doing
no I wouldn't you know I don't give it
no but you do because at the end of the
day I would say I would say B here's
what here's a I'm not defending the fact
that he took steroids I knew from the
second year
I'm saying from the second he walked in
this door I went oh he's definitely
honest that was a lot before I've seen
that was a live album I can't let him I
can't let him slide on this ridiculous
accusations that was a laugh let me see
this what he said this is Birds there we
go 40 47 seconds
hold on
but but here's why that doesn't bother
me b it bothers me because it does it
doesn't be name somebody that has a
product in the supplement space that's
told you the truth that's good that's
why something let's go dirty business
that doesn't mean it's right I'm not
excusing anybody if you sell supplements
that don't work then you're lying and I
I I would never do that you know why you
know why let me okay great question okay
great question let me ask you this
before you go we've said no to how many
supplement companies the reason I
believe in on it this is not a
commercial print on it here's why I
believe it on it I watched [ __ ] Aubry
Marcus and Joe Rogan who owned the
company started the company I watched
them take these supplements themselves
Alpha Brain I watch them with my own
eyes over and over again
if that bothers you are you mad at the
government that they told you about the
vaccines and all this [ __ ] no no I'm not
saying that you know what I'm saying
it's like where do you draw the line are
worthy people are going to get blasted
and and hate when you say you can raise
your testosterone to 700 by doing my
ancestral tennis meaning I.E you buy my
product I'm sorry I have to be honest
here and I think a lot of people agree
with that and that's why we're getting
this you you that that is that is a form
of
um it is it's it's a form you're selling
something smoking mirrors you're selling
something for a lot of money that is not
going to give you the results you are
saying it's giving you you have that I'm
sorry but we we have to be okay and I
like this that's marketing General that
doesn't mean it's right and I and I'm
not saying it is yes but but you can't
defend it either because I'm defending
I'm I'm not defending like the guy
that's what I'm saying I'm saying he's a
good human being
smoking mirrors well but it's also
supplement it's a supplement I think
what I would say about this guy is that
he is a guy who is at the end of the day
if you do what he's saying which are the
nine essential tenants you're probably
gonna be healthier than if you do
something like play video games need
Doritos or whatever it is okay so
overall the overall the message is if
you do this you're probably gonna live a
better life
out think what people are saying is that
hey dude you're claiming that you look
that way
because you do that you look that way
because in fact you do all the all the
Peds and he should have somebody in his
air the way these Hollywood guys do like
the rock like Vin Diesel the mother's in
your ear when you're a kid that's not
right and and you would never do that
and I wouldn't I mean I certainly
wouldn't I can't live with myself that
way from day one on this podcast [ __ ]
day one we've had these conversations we
had it with Rogan too no I've never
assumed you it's like no but I'm saying
God no never crossed my mind I'm not
buying I'm not well I'm not selling [ __ ]
how many times we have really big
sponsors back in the day and I said I
don't use that problem remember when we
lost that sponsored Toyota yeah because
we could it was the stupidest read of
all time I can't do it we should release
that we could not stop laughing to get
through it literally because I was like
man
play that chin do we have that we do but
let's just listen to it just so this you
guys don't know what I'm saying let's
button this up yeah we would it has to
be authentic let's button this up I just
think with the liver King it the space
that he he's in and it doesn't make it
right be to your point and you know but
he's doing what every single person does
in Fitness across the board since the
beginning of time and if you thought he
was natural you're a [ __ ]
it's just that it says the specifics of
his cycle although people will list the
fact that he took like eight different
things
I'm not impressed with like the strength
of what he's taking 120 milligrams test
120 milligrams Deca 50 milligrams a bit
of winstrol and a lot of HGH but it's
farmer grade that's where the number of
like 15K a month comes from is this
shit's really expensive he's taking
about 10 IUS a day which is a high dose
but not unheard of in bodybuilding and
then a few other things that are like
growth hormone agonists that like
promote your own body producing growth
hormone or like igf-1 yeah an igf-1 so
if you take all that growth hormone
stuff together
that's not actually that powerful you
know what I mean and so I think just the
missing component is always he works out
like a [ __ ] maniac and to your point
and you and I talked about that steroids
on the steroids which in this before
he's famous before he launched all this
brand and then CIS drill Primal whatever
it is
um in those emails he talks about how he
works out what do you say 14 times a
week like he's like
I'm doing these workouts
and he was I'm 44 years old I work out
like a Savage I have a problem taking
time off so the work ethic is there the
all that is there his body whether he
was on the stuff or not would be pretty
damn good not probably this good would
be pretty [ __ ] good with the way he
eats trains he trains like a straight up
like it's his job like you and he didn't
think these wouldn't get leaked or
anything like that so we know that's
authentic his work ethic and
discipline's authentic like you would
[ __ ] the cross games up you know what I
mean like he's on These Guys these Pros
yes two-day workouts yeah every [ __ ]
day so let me see this here what what is
it I'll just play because this is how he
squirted this one yeah I take Peds
people say I have AB implants wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait can
we be honest like you you definitely
take Peds you know what [ __ ] it I'm
going to be on for the I'm I'm all right
here we go yeah I prioritize execute
them dominate every every [ __ ]
morning every morning between
that's a political answer right it's
like if you bring if a politician you
put them on the spot that and it to me
it's a real art they're so good at going
over here I mean yeah well it's
politicians all of them do it yeah but
with him it's like yeah I I think that
he's never really actually admitted it
so what we see here is that again
he's what he just did what so people
have a right to be
and I like you know I like the guy I I
had a good time with him but at the end
of the day you know people can be
outrageous continue to point to the fact
that what is getting him there is his
his exercise and his mindset uh that is
dishonest because it's not they'll be
that's one of the facts that 100
dishonesty it's not Brandon it's no beat
hold on I'm with you he [ __ ] up not
him in the steroids but did it say that
he wouldn't be in insane shape with that
work after that diet I didn't say that
no you but you said he's lying to say
that that lifestyle is saying when you
say uh when you say he's not saying
that's the only thing I got him there
listen
listen there there is there is he's
making a lot of money selling his
formula that is the nine ancestral
tenants and all those supplements good
message good supplements uh maybe maybe
not I don't know about supplements I've
used the supplements I'm telling you
good stuff I know supplements good
supplements okay you can keep defending
and what I'm trying to tell you is this
I'm defending his program not him doing
steroids but but you still have to look
at the fact that he is he is saying and
suggesting that what got him there and
what can get you there
what can get you there and that is what
he's saying but get where they'll be you
but get where
to be looking essentially like this he's
never said you're going to look exactly
like me exactly what's implied oh man
and and so he's saying essentially if
you if you look at that
um then you can get your testosterone
from 700 to 1400 using the nine
ancestral tests yeah if I was him I
wouldn't use the numbers yeah if that's
where he [ __ ] up I won't use numbers
yeah but you could say it raises your
testosterone which is okay which is true
if you do deadlifts you eat right you
can bring yeah now that much probably
not at the end of the day for me it it
comes down to this
um I never was gonna buy something I
found him a very entertaining guy and I
was very aware that he was clearly
taking a shitload of stuff yeah you and
I weren't interested on live if you've
been alive you know that correct and
he's playing a character he's walking
around naked wearing uh a pelt and and
yes and not showering and living it and
he's and he was a cartoon character
fungus and it was a great way to Market
his business which he did and continues
to do
if you bought all those supplements and
bought in the nine ancestral tenants
I'm sure you'll be healthier than
otherwise
you live the liver King lifestyle it's
fine you didn't feel good if you think
you're gonna get that way without other
stuff then you're just simply naive and
I think that's where and you deserve it
well yeah and you're a dumbass yeah but
but I'm well having said all that if
you're going to live that if you're
gonna play that game as the liver king
that's Brian Johnson
if you were starting to let's say and
let's say you are don't be like I've
never started someone coming let's say
you got into supplementation yeah and
you wondered and you wanted uh like be
the liver King yeah would you have came
like how should he have dealt with it
should he have came out and said hey
guys I'm on this this and this but I
live this way which also helps yeah it's
a tough place to be what would you do
and then my other question for you is
name one single example in the fitness
space that launched a supplement company
that told us exactly what cycle they're
taking from day one I think what you are
sympathetic and I I don't like when
people pile on I think he made a mistake
can you take accountability for it yeah
it does not take away from his overall
message and he's actually a good person
the overall message I'm on board with I
can ride with yeah of course he's on
steroid you [ __ ] idiots yeah
yeah
it's it's it continues to be a
complicated subject because I think
anyone
anyone selling a makeup line Kardashians
anyone selling any kind of longevity uh
Beauty almost anyone with the exception
of like uh like Lane Norton who's a
scientist and Andy Galvin certain guys
but they're not living on Yachts but the
people that have done very well made a
lot of money almost all are in one way
or another doing things there's a catch
why the steroids they're certainly how
do you feel about plastic surgery how do
you feel about butt implants how do you
feel about Botox how do you feel about
all these things when you look at the
Kardashians and a girls whose 11 says I
want to look like that something that's
where he gets dicey I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna buy Kylie's makeup that's why he
gets like well Kylie's makeup line ain't
gonna make you look like Kylie no a very
expensive plastic surgery she went
through a lot of pain yeah yeah and I
used to and I used to do everybody I
know I used to defend the Kardashians
right with that stuff I'm like oh
they're gorgeous they look better and
then I forget who it was it might have
been uh um
um the Stefano yeah uh DeStefano uh
Chrissy D was like yeah but would you
feel the same way if you had a daughter
who's 13 who's like Dad I'm buying Kylie
Jenner's makeup because apparently this
can make me look like her you would go
no no that you don't want that to be a
North star yeah but also if my son tiger
who's really into fitness stuff I went
hey Dad I'm gonna start the liver King's
protocol I'm gonna live this lifestyle
to say oh cool buddy you can sleep on
bamboo and eat liver and stuff like that
I'll support all that but you know he's
also I would tell him straight up you
know he's on a like artificial PT's dude
the Muslim Fitness Empire Muslim Fitness
Magazine he built off this I mean it was
all it was all nutrition and exercise
and all of it was great but the models
the people we were trying to get to
unattainable we're unattainable without
a pharmacy of drugs which I didn't know
back then dude I didn't know until I was
like 24. I I got a flat top when I was
12 and had my mom buy me whole milk
because I thought I would look like
Arnold schwarzeneg here my mom's like
this how you do it I'm like I just left
and drink milk and drink I have a flat
top and I start talking like them she's
like yeah that'll get you there yeah
dumbass even you said when you tried to
put on real weight and you're a huge guy
who puts on muscle easily you said it
took you like a year and a half oh my
God yeah it's hard work man if you do it
the right if you do it naturally and I
think maybe that's why I have a soft
spot for the liver King because I've
been gym since I was about fourth grade
and I know how hard that dude's work
even with or without steroids to get to
that and that discipline it takes it's
tough what's the bodybuilder thing guys
you're like [ __ ] tough I think well I
could you well it was like Equus what
was that that documentary he took he
took all the everything with a Russian
scientist he was a biker and still
couldn't come close so a lot of it is
you know how good of an athlete are you
you're not gonna and most people you
walk on the street past you have no idea
they're on steroids because I've met so
many guys who are like really tell me
what they're on and I'm like oh it's
just you must have been so much skinny
or you're not using it right tell me
what you're on so I know what
sometimes they look fantastic sometimes
you're like you look so good this is my
this is my again I'm not defending I'm
saying this is the society we live in
name something that you see that's not
artificial so if you see a girl on
Instagram right they doctor the pictures
the filters these days for women for men
all this stuff all of this it's all a
lot of it's smoking we have a great
point because I think there's something
wrong with our culture maybe right or
here let me play Devil's Advocate one
it's probably something wrong with our
culture cultures have never been
different
cultures have never been different we've
always tried to be more beautiful women
work courses have made their ways tiny
and they would faint uh you've got a lot
of Chinese girls find their feet
primitive cultures are not probably
shouldn't say perimeter cultures why do
things
scarification rituals sure uh all of
those things were meant to the human
beings have gone into all kinds of
decorations enhancement and financing
we've also altered our states and now
with technology Gene editing we are in
the New Frontier where you're gonna be
able to like pretty much anything anyone
want yeah and so this might just be uh
the movement toward a form of
transhumanism people want to live
forever this is an expression of people
wanting to be bigger stronger faster and
ultimately and live longer and healthier
and not be in the hospital but they're
never going to change it and we're going
to get closer to it with technology I
agree and then the standard of beauty is
really I think the bars can get lower
because if everybody can attain it from
you know paying a doctor and we can or
taking a pill whatever we get to then
the level of beauty it's like well
here's there's tens everywhere here's my
thoughts you still agree with but let me
button this up but let me before you
button up I just want to see so we're
talking about Society it's like even
when we're talking about Teslas and you
know electric cars and stuff like that
and you say you know it's that's gonna
be the the thing and gas power's gonna
be gone but even in the message of that
this isn't political this these are
facts even the message of Teslas and
electric cars and we think it's the
right thing to do but underneath all of
it it's actually not it's smoke and
mirrors because if you look into it in
the lithium batteries and the faster
cars go and how much they weigh and now
death was gonna be up on the roads it's
actually not but it feels free right no
everything is smoking mares it's
everything like when you look when you
get down to the nitty-gritty of really
most things that are making so much
money whatever whatever business you're
into shoes you're into it's you know the
Nikes I'm into yeah they cost into slave
labor they cost four dollars to make
it's everything is a great contradiction
of being a human being you try to be
good and you're probably being bad and
it's impossible not to miss right and so
you're bringing up such a great point I
think at the end of the day though the
lesson here for Brian Johnson liver King
for anybody else live your children for
a huge for a huge movie star who might
be pretending to be straight and is
actually gay whatever it might be
you're going to get found out the
problem with lying
in regardless of where it is in your
life just know you're not going to get
away with it ultimately you can't you
just can't um and I have for LeBron for
LeBron if you want and I'm saying he is
but if for Tom Brady if it means I get
to watch you play for 10 more years and
you're taking HGH and you know you're
not physically harming people and you're
it gets 10 years of joy out of my life
and you're taking HH and protects your
knees do it buddy [ __ ] do it I get 10
more years to experience your greatness
I agree I don't care
I totally agree I don't care
um yeah I just think at the end of the
day it's it's a [ __ ] really it's kind
of new for us but it's not and it's a
really tough thing and when you're in
the Limelight and you've made you've
built your fortune off of a certain look
and a certain Persona that requires all
the work and a little help on the on the
side
and letting people know that help on the
side is going to tear it all down it
becomes very difficult yeah but now
nowadays all of us know most of us you
know with all the guy like Derek from
plates more weights or whatever
Place more dates yeah sorry more plays
more dates more place more dates
I'm like plates on play yeah why did he
why did he go bad on it's that's a great
question I'm with B on this and I love
Derek you know I love you place more
dates
uh again maybe it's because I get so
much [ __ ] all the time but when I saw
that I went what are you doing Derek
what are you doing man you you Derek's a
very smart smart and when it comes to
like breaking down steroids and now
you're not he is the best human being on
Earth to do that as far as entertainment
and known his he's so good I love this
man he's phenomenal at his job the best
there is Rogan had him have you met him
so good yeah oh we've gone back and
forth tax and uh yeah and uh
um DMS
um so if I ever want to go on steroids
not for you we'll get to you he's a guy
no no no just go up the road uh but so
uh doesn't matter right so uh but when I
saw Derek do that the part of me because
we live again this is another problem in
society that we're talking about with
smoke and mirrors but the mentality to
tear the be the first one to tear
somebody down it breaks my heart like oh
you could have you could have called him
be like hey dude how do you before I
drop this like what do you want to do or
like you know like or if you want I'll
have you on we can talk about this I
think there's a better way to do it
because we're so quick to society in
general because they haven't risked what
other people have risked to get to a
certain point whatever it is they want
to tear them down man because that makes
them feel better I don't know I just
don't subscribe to it I don't know how I
feel but now now to on to play Devil's
Advocate up with Derek on plates more
dates is it his job because he does a
naughty or not his job was he kind of
his job kind of but if you get an email
look I'd say this is there but also
because it didn't come from an actual
doctor came from his bodybuilding coach
isn't there a hippo laws here is
somebody getting sued here I don't know
because isn't it if it's I don't blame
Derek because Derek that's his show
that's his job that you if you're if
you're anybody who's doing if you're in
a situation like Brian Johnson or liver
King yeah don't call Brian John I know
I'm sorry if you're interested
yeah if you're a guy also on PDS yes if
you're a guy like liver King you
um have to know that the reality of the
internet is that it's a truth Seeker
it's a truth Seeker no it's no it I
wouldn't call it true Seeker I would say
it's a career Destroyer but but but if
you're not they're not the truth though
right but like so what I'm saying is
that Hornby even if you are they're
gonna come for you well they're always
going to come for you yeah that's what I
told them everybody's going to come
they're coming but what do you mean I go
you're getting too famous yeah they're
coming they're coming but but I'm trying
to say is that that kind of situation
with with there are very smart people
like Derek who can break this down and
are going to say this is impossible for
you to look this way otherwise okay but
then he did get all this information so
he can back it up it's very hard for him
he's not he doesn't owe anybody anything
he just owes his audience the truth
let me ask you he said he did a place
more dates he did a daddy or not on
Rogan like a ton of people yeah he
talked about my uh Olympic when I was on
trt my wiener wouldn't work just stopped
working really and he was like you're
probably taking too much we went back
and forth that's how me and him met what
were you taking
uh testosterone because I got my levels
checked do any animal or anything like
that yeah I'm all set on your expertise
on this but no I'm just saying no I
talked to it yeah no but what caused the
dick thing was it too much testosterone
yeah that's what he's saying like maybe
they recommend too much of a high dose I
mean because sometimes you take too much
it will cause that and some people and
it causes uh your sperm production to go
to zero right zero which is has been an
issue for me right so I'll talk to the
place more dates when him have gone are
you taking testosterone now no okay yeah
because but you never were you did it
for a little bit well just because I was
it was so so low and they said they
think because of Combat Sports and since
I've been working out and like doing so
much stuff since I was in fourth grade
yeah to go dead that all like way to go
to football in fourth grade what are you
doing but uh way to go I loved it but in
fourth grade for getting him the head
you know to doing all that stuff
pituitary gland well they said just the
constant like the adrenaline the
testosterone like it just stopped
working so much my adrenals are [ __ ]
too yeah so I got on it you know I felt
good for a little bit but then once my
wiener stopped working
I'd rather look like [ __ ] Brendan
Fraser on a new movie than have not had
my wiener working yes you know what I'm
saying yes yes 100 okay I didn't know
that okay so but my thing let me ask you
this yeah if you're Derek that plays
more dates and I know you'd be yeah you
wouldn't do it
you wouldn't do it I know things about
certain people that would absolutely
ruin their career destroy them yeah we
all do I would never that's not my job
that's not what I do
it's just not the way the world should
work now I guess what again I'm such a
fan of Derek well I woke up when I
literally I was like man I wonder what
the [ __ ] why would you do that this poor
guy granted he did lie stuff like that
but then I went it is kind of his job
right it is if he doesn't add it or not
and he has to break I have no problem
with her doing it in a way because it's
you know I I don't either because like
that is what he does
I mean you got to know that that's gonna
it's like being mad it's like being mad
about Don Lemon lied to about covet it's
his job
[Laughter]
I don't know
hold on why why I'm suppressed on
Instagram
why do you think this all happened like
why why did his coach go bad on him his
coach is the one oh
that's the there's the [ __ ] root of
the problem hey coach yeah well I'm not
working with him ever again all his
employees are going oh wait hey whoa
whoa be cool man let me watching why
would you do this that's spilling the
beans yeah well I assume that he's the
notoriety and money and blatant
disregard for the truth probably irks a
lot of people yes on planet Earth in the
fitness space in the world absolutely
because we're in a time now where
actually it is a lot more acceptable and
you mentioned somebody like who's honest
about their steroids and also sell
supplements Greg Doucette is an example
of that recently because he's made
videos talking about every single thing
he's taken and also has started a
supplement line that's a more recent
phenomenon I think that you like
afforded the ability to but we do live
in a space now we can do that so hey
Mark but we're not Mark Deuce that how's
this supplement line going is he is he I
think pretty good just because he's he's
very like it's it's his brand so the
issue is when you're representing
somebody else's brand I'd assume like
they don't want you to do it or or you
know with this guy it might just be more
complicated I assume his marketing team
was like don't do that because yes it
does undercut potentially he decided on
the LIE double down but that when people
look at you and you're brazing because
it wouldn't happen just to some
bodybuilder nobody knows like the guy
wouldn't send Derek you know hey expose
this [ __ ] guy at my local gym who
says he's not on test it'd be cool like
Hey Garrett
I think the liver King
it brought a lot of this on himself by
being that
that opinionated that aggressive with
his health message that aggressive with
his lifestyle message and that rich off
of that message and I think when you are
not consistent when you are not living
the way you are saying you are living
they're going to come for you yes when
you're giving all the credit
verbally patrols are coming and and
without apology to your
supplements your natural tale to nose
supplements and your exercise and your
Primal tenants
and no credit to the other stuff
and it's like Game of Thrones steroids
are coming they come steroids come they
come the truth is coming yeah they come
so he was very very aggressive about it
and and insulting to other people
who lived a different way and when you
do that play stupid games Win stupid
prize
oh he was I watched that a lot I watched
him be very very aggressive in other
words you tell me why plants are good
for you you know and stuff like that you
just make fun of people and he was he
was roasting people hard so you're gonna
get roasted yeah right yeah there was
already when we had him on the number of
people you know he was already a
controversial guy because people were
like you know and you know my thing was
you're you're a character to be honest
you and Jim want a man and Mark I didn't
like no apology no me neither I'm so
glad he came I said he can come back
yeah I'd love to talk to him sure but
yeah yeah but no when he came on I
wasn't that familiar with like I saw
some clips when I was a girl he's just
eating livery's Jack still really doing
preaching about health all right I guess
we'll have them on yeah is he you know
is he gonna be funny smart he's gonna be
good at the conversations and so I
wanted to be like this is gonna be
stupid I'd love to I was like oh he's
actually a good dude like off air No
cameras I was like oh he's actually a
sweet person and also what against I
have a sweet spot for him amazing father
dude I'm on board with all that yes so
the steroids I assume yeah yeah no [ __ ]
no no let me tell you Barry Bonds took
him yeah I mean I I think I think that
he just needs to come clean and yeah
steak ownership yeah take ownership
that's all you know what he should do
he's come out on a Jocko's podcast
complete ownership
and Jocko just sticks him with facts
yeah you gotta you can't you like when I
was talking to him he couldn't come on
here I actually uh recommend he goes on
Schultz's show and I connected him in
Schultz
here wouldn't work because you and I
like him so much
and I literally don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not the guy to do it now ratings have
been good you know people ratings what
about the rating
hopefully people watch but it's not what
I do hold them but also kill it with
humor yeah and then he'll let him talk
and they'll do their thing there's a
bunch of guys you and I would be like
yeah you did stories who gives a [ __ ]
hey dude so how's the testicles going
for you know you're right though when
you say the entire space is so full of
snake oil and the entire space of
self-help and wellness and all that it's
just so full of Bro Science and so full
of promises and I just have never
I just mean potatoes baby yeah meat and
potatoes that's what works yeah just
worked out the Chelsea when do the
steroids do it don't lie to your
followers if steroids work do them right
if you're gonna do them right they do
them if you if you again they only work
if you do them and you live a strict
healthy lifestyle that you can take out
stories you want but keep living the way
you're doing and you know you have a
beer gut it's just gonna get more
bloated it's a lot it might get a little
more strength and you're gonna have some
weird marks on your ass that's all that
happens yeah I get some acne on your
back it can be good yeah still a warlock
baby it's still a warlock I'm gonna do
some [ __ ] I'm gonna get into power
now now do you wanna
is it your turn to own up to your
steroid usage okay guys here's the thing
well if you're like I'm on meth I do a
lot I would believe if I would believe
you on meth more so than still I'm on
I'm on a lot of Jesus in case you guys
are wondering why I'm so clear-eyed and
full-hearted you did call me yesterday
and hit me with a pretty religious line
but you were in the so heated about it I
was gonna make funny I was like I did
say that I was gonna look up to the sky
website and you need to I said I said
look at this guy sometimes once in a
while look at the sky and pray to your
lord and savior thank your Creator first
of all for all the things that are good
in your life and you've never talked
like this ever to me ask him for
strength and truth and forgiveness your
best the let the angels of your best
nature that's what he said Angel is
beautifully spoken so I didn't interrupt
sinner Saint that's what I say we're
bipolar Apes Sinners Saints everything
in between
let always be moving toward the saint
and you you went to church one time he
went to church one time and you start
preaching I've been in soccer for a long
time I've been a secret [ __ ] you hey hey
snake oil you want to trash my boy liver
King and judge and you're saying I'm a
seeker of Jesus Christ allow me to
forget right now he knows not what he
says and I give love I give love hold on
hold on hey does the hey does seeking
the the Lord and Savior include washing
your [ __ ] in a public bathroom I'm
ashamed of you Jesus Christ God wants my
whistle clean not in a public bathroom
where we watch her I never put my pieces
in a public bathroom I have it on film
really yes my my ex-wife has me on the
[ __ ]
a lot of pictures of me on the [ __ ]
just like this like that because you
catch me and every once in a while if
I'm just being I'm talking or whatever
I'm being cocky on the plane I'll just
get a picture of me and me on the
[ __ ] and then she'll zoom in in just
this part it's so disgusting yeah some
wrinkles I'm just like get me the [ __ ]
out of here right now please erase that
let's button this up chin are you mad at
liver King no why I don't know you seem
like you're mad at him no but real quick
did are you guys sure that his the
bodybuilding coach is what leaked it or
something it got leaked some other yeah
yeah they said that right uh I didn't
see it anyway yeah Derek talked about it
and again it was this information is
given to him by the bodybuilding coach
with a lot of redacted information
um it's redacted so he gave him only a
little bit like there was just certain
things in there where it's like he's
going over the documents and he's like
oh this personal information is redacted
so like the guy took links to conceal
some information because he didn't want
that to go public and perhaps conceal
this identity too yeah that's that's a
that's a real uh breach of trust isn't
it that's just that something must have
happened it's a breach of trust but
I I don't assume that
it's the same thing as a doctor-patient
confident confidential yeah right right
so he was getting it from you know but
motto of the story get your get all your
supplements from a doctor
don't trust your Meathead gym coach yeah
because down the road he might throw you
into the bus my only issue is it was a
private email that's my own issue it's a
private email you should have just I
never tell you I saw um I was at Gold's
Gym in Venice probably 15 years ago and
uh it was so [ __ ] wild this beautiful
woman she was probably 35 maybe maybe a
little older and she was a fitness girl
and she came walking out and a giant man
uh walked up to her and said something
like uh Jennifer
and she goes yeah and he goes I've been
looking for you how are you and she goes
I'm good who are you and he goes well
honey opens up a badge and he says I'm
uh I'm from the DEA uh and I got some
questions uh I think you know why I'm
here yeah oh my God
she just stopped and she went oh okay
and he goes yeah dude do you want to
come over here do you want to talk here
and I remember just going
[ __ ] man what do you think she's doing
prostitution she was probably selling
steroids in the gym yes or you know she
was running a whole thing something was
going on with steroids because he
mentioned that wow and I didn't say I
felt like I couldn't wait I was like I
gotta get out of here oh I would have
got my phone out no it was it was before
all that he was right he was it was so
he was so clearly a professional law
enforcement he was a law enforcement guy
who had been on her tail and found her
your father you're [ __ ] it's like our
friend who did you know who did six
years in federal pen for drug
trafficking he said when they show up oh
in their black SUVs it's three guys that
guy's just a chat four black one four
black SUVs show up
that's the feds they got you and you
better start and talking and here's the
thing and they've been they've been
doing the research for a few months for
a year yeah a year yeah when they
finally come get you
they got a case you go in the can they
got a case my buddy my buddy uh was on a
International he does this
internationally and he he was they got
this huge drug deal this Jamaican drug
dealer and and the guy was running like
some crazy operation you know and they'd
been watching him for a year and uh and
he said yeah I was just on a Stakeout
this guy blah blah I said I think I said
so we're going to close in tomorrow or
something and I said why would he be
doing all this stuff out in the open he
goes well because when you've been doing
it long enough you start to think you're
smarter than we are and you start to
think you can get away with it and then
you start taking chances and that's when
we get you but we have all the resources
we got all the resources that's uh that
whole thing with we had buddies who did
dab on that stuff and I was like are you
you think you're smarter than the fed
that's hilarious you know that like
Harvard graduates and their only goal is
to focus on your [ __ ] this Idaho
stabbing is interesting though because
they can't find this [ __ ] and
this guy came into our house with a nice
and stabbed four kids college students
and two girls two guys right yeah and
whoever he is they don't have they the
FBI can't find well but they're not
releasing all the information they have
some suspects but they want to leak it
because I think he's going to run and
the other problem they're having is the
kids went on winter break so they're not
in the school so it's kind of a dead
town it's a college town so they don't
know because everyone's gone yeah so
they have no people to talk to there's
no Witnesses but what they did they had
a forensic guy who was in the house and
he's like this person's not professional
it's so sloppy like there's so much
blood and the way he went in and then
also like there was a dog upstairs and
like if it was a serial killer or
someone that's done this before they
went they would have went in during this
time and with the the knowing that
there's a dog knowing there's two people
upstairs that he can't get to in time
like this was it's very sloppy and the
amount of blood and they're going to
catch them but they do think it might be
connected with this other murder I
forget was that of a two couple just
randomly murdered same way that was in
somewhere on the West Coast
I mean seriously like like the guy that
cop who catfished that teenage girl
killed her grandparents and mother and
then took her in a car they caught him
and he died in a shootout but Jesus
Christ yeah I was like how are you this
[ __ ] evil horrible horrible what else
you got June
uh you guys want to listen to Toyota
Untold but yeah
the funniest podcast read of all time we
couldn't get through it
yeah he ever just sit around while
you're scrolling through some of your
podcasts and go you know what man
Toyota just isn't a car company
I say that all the time I go what no
what else they are though you know you
know what they are they're a new podcast
called Toyota Untold
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] you so much
[ __ ] you you guys want to listen to the
Toyota
that's so funny let's do this hey who
gives a [ __ ] if we [ __ ] up you ready you
ready
[Laughter]
damn bro you know what man
what's so funny
you're funny bro what
why are you laughing
I can't do this
oh my God what a terrible podcast
no hold on hold on let's see all right
let me try it you ready hey
B you know what one thing I'm noticing a
lot
you don't
[Music]
all right
baby you never just sit around
what are you supposed to do Chinese the
Toyota car only pocket hey you want the
worst podcast if you thought Toyota car
shut up
all right
the longest running cars on the road
the Highland they're the best cars on
the planet they want to do [ __ ] who
decided to do a podcast who would that
company who is now fired who is now
fired who's like let's do uh we'll do
stories about your Toyota which I can
understand maybe boy that is the main
character when I was in my tutorial you
were on the road and see Cameron think
man how'd they create that we may have
done that and gotten paid and I want to
apologize to our listeners one time we
lost I want to thank Camry oh [ __ ]
that's me laugh so goddamn God damn
that's funny that still made me cry [ __ ]
was the hot side holy [ __ ] ah you
watched any of the World Cup oh yeah
yeah watch it Ron uh lose to the US yep
I'm kind of rooting the U.S annoys me
because it's it's not they're not
Americans they're all like they're like
oh he's our best players
but he had but he was born in the US so
yeah come on you're not even speaking
not our best Slayer polsik is he's he's
uh he's born here but I think his
parents have Croatian descent but he's
he's the best player look at this the
Iran a soccer team refuses they paid for
that they paid for that you see what
happened well they they threatened
through another family family yeah
they're like oh cool you don't want to
sing see what happens you see what these
[ __ ] seeing like [ __ ] Mariah
Carey on the last game [ __ ] he they
they hit those high notes yeah well I
would too you're gonna threat my family
I'll sing there's what's going on a lot
of protests right now it's crazy man
it's crazy and they're killing a lot of
people that it's just it's bad she was
arrested for not wearing the statement
job yeah that was that she was Sparks
herself she's murdered too yeah
yeah
um
the Iranian people are going through
some [ __ ] man yeah people people think I
hope they have problems here in America
if I go into China right now try going
to [ __ ] yeah and Iraq Iran is young
people who are just so tired of this
[ __ ] they're so tired did you see uh
because you know obviously the head
coach of the U.S stock team has nothing
to do with it but somebody on the U.S
soccer team you know America runs it
because they want to stand with you know
these protesters they took off the the
Islamic logo on the flag of Iran Iran
yeah took the local off and posted it
like whatever like you know uh for the
reason they posted their flag yeah they
took the logo off
Iran did not take kindly to that they
were Furious so that we had to take it
down apologize we put it back up so
they're entering the coach after we
thought they tied U.S tied England 0-0
which you know it's crazy we celebrate
that but yeah they did tie them
um and I asked the coach you know do you
have anything to say about taking the
Islamic logo you know symbol off the
Iran Iranian flag he's like I I don't
run the twit I'm not even aware of it
what happened he goes I'm a soccer coach
and then they're like well what about
the U.S submarine that's near the Iran
like all this [ __ ] and he's like I'm not
up on my politics man again I'm a U.S
men's soccer coach they're like no more
questions like holy [ __ ] I mean yeah it
is
ah
I was gonna go to this model real quick
but maybe we'll save it for later
actually let's just do it now so this
woman she's a model nothing crazy yeah
hell nothing crazy about this other than
uh you've had dress codes there at Qatar
Croatian Serbian uh they're all so
beautiful
yeah that's like oh wow
so yeah apparently she was fine though
she was able she was able to be you know
get out of there like stoned even the
Qatari even the qataris were like I mean
you know look at her
I mean she's [ __ ] gorgeous yeah
but her Instagram even though Iranians
were like okay all right we get that
yeah I mean you know did you put a bow
tie on top right it's just all Croatian
[ __ ] yeah or even find those outfits I
mean you know they'll make up you make
them you make them for her
there you go yeah she's cool so this is
a Disney animated movie that I was
supposed to do I guess better than it
did but it's so it's there's an lb
there's a gay kid there's a boy who has
a crush on another boy yeah so there's a
gay character in there and we know you
guys talked about it before a lot of
times you think these big companies are
pushing uh diversity because I mean this
company was like Disney Disney was like
the real world does have gay kids in it
right and and it's not far-fetched to
think that one of the kids could be gay
of course right because there are a lot
of kids who are watching this who might
be gay I don't know ten percent three
percent whatever they are and so you
know yeah but let's say three four five
percent but either way yeah but there
there are gay kids and so that's a
reality so if you were to go to a school
you'd find a certain percent of those
children that are gay or at least
confused about their sexuality and
that's not hard to believe right that
there would be that but it's been more
and more Americans the world's just not
ready for it yet it's amazing well no
that's why we fired their CEO like this
woke agenda they've had they're eating
all the days so started Buzz Light
you're right started Buzz Lightyear now
it started with this it's and then that
movie uh was it Bros that they're trying
to mimic
bridesmaids so you're they're over three
there's nothing wrong with the majority
of Americans going I'm just not into it
because the majority is not gay so
they're gone I'm not into it same reason
it's okay for Buco I'm not into in the
movie Crash but uh what was it the Asian
movie
uh the crust uh crazy Rich crazy crazy
rich Asian yeah cool I didn't see it I
would bring my kid to Strange World
because my son at 11 knows about gay
stuff and he'd be like he'd have his own
take on it well so I'd make it before
you guys go too far into this this is
basically um so the movie flopped it
should have done way better than it did
yeah and then um so the L lgbtq
Community feels there's a conspiracy
that maybe Disney made this movie this
way so it would flop so that they won't
have to make any more movies with you
know gay people
lgbqt here's the thing because if this
movie did phenomenal then they would
make more yeah so the glass for you is
half empty because it just happened to
bomb which every single movie that
they've experienced and tried the stuff
out with same with that other movie Bros
what about Fairy Godmother when the
Fairy Godmother was a dude what was that
a remember that I don't know that was on
ABC the black guy it was the favorite
yeah that was ABC yeah I think so but
it's just it's make it's making good
movies I think otherwise because so this
also you guys both know Patrick uh David
you guys have both been on the show yeah
uh he said he took his kids to go watch
it within 10 minutes his 10 year old son
said do I he doesn't want to watch this
so they left so it just wasn't that good
of a movie yeah so the the apparently
the movie itself wasn't that good so how
much did that do with an openly gay
character get fighting Nemo and had a
gay character it probably would have
crushed anyway right they did Ellen the
fish was gay yeah yeah can I see can I
see the the tell me you tell me toe
Mater from Cars ain't sucking dick right
I like Patrick David we got to cut this
out though obviously okay let me just
see this well there's no mention of them
being gay so I don't know where that's
what Brandon said I'm not even sure I
thought it was a girl I have no clue I
mean
but anyways it's a little much you know
I wouldn't take my son it's a little
much you know yeah to come to explain it
right now yeah it's just it's confusing
form you know it's just wait a little
while yeah no I'm good
here's a question Disney's learned the
hard way
yeah um so take your prices are insane
too work on that
incredibly insane for two people it's
not yeah a quick Combat Sports one
that's happening right now so
Patty pimblet was accusing Jake Jake
Paul's fighter being fixed which is
already kind of crazy right with
Anderson Silva so then Jake Paul
challenged Patty pembler to one a one
million dollar boxing match but he would
fly Patty to Puerto Rico where he's at
first do it yeah you can't do official
because UFC of course wait there's even
it's crazy as is well he bet him that
and then um it was for a million bucks
I'll just play the video for you quickly
uh
I was really wanting to like you I
really
good little thing going for you man but
then you come out and you say my fight
against Anderson Silva was rigged I'm
sick and tired of this narrative it's
pathetic it's stupid you're
disrespecting the own goat of your own
sport you're saying that Anderson Silva
is a criminal you're saying he's a fraud
you're saying that Viacom one of the
biggest media companies in the world is
doing criminal stuff that's what you're
saying
it's stupid it's me driving and filming
this I have a proposition for you since
you wouldn't rig a fight right all right
that's far
fly to Puerto Rico I'll get you a
private jet
we can do five three minute rounds
boxing if you win I'll give you a
million dollars which is what you
deserve to get paid Patty
you know it but the UFC is not paying
you that you deserve to get paid more
but if I win you have to join the United
Fighters Association and help me sign up
all of the fighters in the UK Petty
can't do that that's far since you
wouldn't work
I like Jake Paul I love him yeah I'm
just so impressed with this box and wise
out I mean tough for Pat Uh Paul's tough
for anybody right now who's not a boxer
or who does other mixed yeah real quick
Patty did respond he said he accepts the
fight but since he's fighting next week
anyways he has to wait you know week
after and then he says he can't go to
Puerto Rico obviously since he's
fighting but then he'll meet him as soon
as you have CPI and Spar there
is that still sparring yeah but it
wouldn't Pat I didn't get why after the
fight Patty went fly down to Costa Rica
no I think he wants him to go right now
oh no that's stupid yeah no no he's got
a good he said he's gonna fight have one
day rest and then meet him at the pi
the same size or is Patty a lot smaller
uh well it's huge yeah but he puts on
weight yeah but that's not he's a big
boy natural big boy he's a big big frame
yeah yeah who's bigger for you've been
with both of them uh Jake's a little
bigger Jake's a little more naturally
bigger yeah more muscle yeah how do you
you know when he gets big he puts on a
lot of fat there but the the thing the
downside for Patty like he should do it
make the million dollars but with Jake
and he did the same thing with Dana like
he had to make fighter pay equal and do
all that stuff
it's never going to happen also if Patty
would decide to do that and then he's
forced contractually to be in this
Fighter's basic Union it's gonna [ __ ]
his UFC career yeah because then Dana's
been like all right here give me give me
your give me your golden shirt that
we've given you give that back and
they're gonna start promoting he won't
be the co-main event anymore or main
event or there's no more main events in
Liverpool so the upside for Paddy's is
not very high right it [ __ ] him he's
like I'm down in fight but I'm not
signing the fighter Union thing that
ain't happening
because then you know I'm still
currently employed with UFC and if I'm
the face of that that you want me to
recruit other Fighters then I'm the
enemy of Dana White and then I'm I just
signed a new deal with them so I have
six lights to him he's going to screw me
yeah it wouldn't be very smart for Patty
yeah
loves team Sparta but it ain't happening
if those are the guys I don't think
that's gonna happen yeah and these are
just quick ones this is a
I guess it's Chinese brother and sister
too man I've seen these they're still at
it I do believe it's it's uh sped up a
little bit but still I don't know about
that these guys [ __ ]
refresh
it's definitely sped up look at the [ __ ]
the feet the footwork
I don't know dude they've been playing
they've been fighting for a long time
these kids I don't know if it is it's
good they're going I don't see a sped up
at all those sped up for sure when he
when he went jump like yeah
it doesn't work on our eyes now they're
talented no matter what and they're this
fastest no matter what head trauma what
are they doing what's it that's the
thing I was looking at too what the [ __ ]
is this younger yeah yeah I mean
kids you know
they didn't look like anyone's getting
that hit in the head though their their
defense was insane no one's going to
hear it but nothing they were crazy
they're both super talented Killers but
this is the I'm not sure when this
podcast happened this Mike Tyson talking
about when he was younger he fought kids
and their parents
father when I was a kid though yeah in
the ring in the street you caught a son
and his daddy on the same day yeah
and whoop them both yeah how was that
bro what was it you say six six what
16-17 I was 11.
I was 11.
if you're the dad you're probably the
laughingstock in the neighborhood until
they found out years later he became a
heavyweight championship yeah yeah like
that's knocked out that's fine when he
was 13 he would beat up most
and we can end on this one
I don't know how this happens but is she
slipping this
how I learned to eat spaghetti in Kenya
let that mouth do baby oh that's
impressive
she's whining Owen's wondering what you
do with the wiener of course everyone is
past Halloween always
[Laughter]
yeah
that's beautiful
yeah
whoever that guy is I love him you're
sweating uh I'll try and slurp a noodle
like they've come to the show Providence
Rhode Island this Thursday that's
tonight tonight Thursday Friday Saturday
shows are damn near sold out December
1st through the 3rd Providence Rhode
Island Comic connection come get you
some that sweet award-winning thick
nectar tiger thick will be available at
all shows and exclusive merch can only
get on tour that's Providence Rhode
Island this Thursday Friday Saturday
that's tonight tomorrow and Saturday
Providence come on out
Naples Florida off the economy come
December one two three and four that's
Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday this
weekend so tonight tomorrow Saturday
Sunday boss messages left Boston
December 29 30 31. I'm not going to make
it I'm going to die San Diego California
Mike drop Comedy Club January 5 6 and 7
Fort Wayne Indiana January 12th to the
14th Dania Florida January 19 to the
21st I'm on the road Zanies
to four in Nashville and then New York
New York Sony Hall March 11th
um in uh New York at Sony Hall come get
some can't wait all right is that it all
right kids that is it this the fun kid
we're out